any of your colleagues in the
Conservative Party take your view having
it's quite a sizable number actually in
the parliamentary party and in the party
at at large I'm not going to put a
number on it because it's very much a
moving feast at the moment we obviously
had some clarification from the Prime
Minister last weekend about the timing
of the triggering of article 50 this
idea of having a great repeal bill but
clearly the the big issue is going to be
the terms on which we leave the EU and
the terms of our continuing relationship
with EU member states but just let me
ask you about you know the number of I
also bet those that think this way but
the number who feel free to speak out
it's almost as if the remains have
disappeared within the Conservative
Party we know they were the majority
people like you people like Hannah sue
berry are speaking out but many have
headed to the hills
amber Rudd I mean she's not that
secretary bound by collective
responsibility but she was have vocal
remain supporter yet she came out with
that speech were you horrified at
conference well I was I was very
surprised that amber had put forward
that proposal about the listing of
foreign workers because that's not the
amber Rudd that I know and I worked
alongside in the in the cabinet and I
think it's on those things I mean
incidentally she was saying and others
saying it's a consultation but the
trouble with these sorts of policies is
that they send out a message about the
the party about the way that we want to
approach people coming to this country
bringing their talents their skills here
and I do think as a message that we want
to send out to to the wider world and to
reduce the word repugnant and that's
used by Steve Hilton former adviser to
then Prime Minister David Cameron well I
think it's it is I probably would
actually I mean I think it's it's a
really inadvisable way to proceed I mean
there's no doubt people do care in this
country about the levels of immigration
and I think that we've moved from
position where in 2005 where Michael had
was part leader in that election he
talked to immigration and that debate
was shut down by the then Labour
government but we appear to have now
gone through almost you know 180 degrees
the other way I suppose which is that
actually now where we're now saying
we're going to open ocean shut the
borders we don't want people to come
here and I think that's also
we want to see as a country I think
Steve Hilton has a point this morning
and he writes about having an open
country about people coming here look I
represent a constituency with a large
international university and they would
be a huge disadvantage if they didn't
have academics coming here if they
didn't have students coming here you
know we saw the disturbing development
on Friday of academics at the LSE being
told unless you have a British passport
you know we don't want to have you
advising the UK government and that also
seems a strange development to me - and
another one picking out from the
conference Jeremy Hunt another remainder
of course coming out with extraordinary
idea that somehow the NHS will become he
Trump's self-sufficient in in pretty
staffing in ten years time it's
presumably not achievable we surprised
he said something like that well I
wasn't entirely surprised because there
has been a debate around the cabinet
table about obviously in training
medical students is a huge investment
for this country and I think we should
ask ourselves why is that the so many
having been trained then decide
immediately to to go overseas so what
can we do to incentivize people to to
stay here but again you see the message
you can give is well actually we only
want British doctors we don't want
foreign expertise coming here and it's
varying listen to some interviews given
by people working in the health service
over the last couple of days saying
actually our health service is stronger
because we do have people from overseas
and also our doctors go overseas again
to build up their experience which they
can then bring back which benefits
patients here so I think all of those
those signals are it's quite it's it's
rather confusing
when actually what we want to be
focusing on is how do we give that
messages there about being in an open
country that welcomes all talents to
come here but we want do the best thing
whether it's for our public services
whether it's for our businesses and
other organisations and making sure
they've got access to the best talents
possible so you know these questions
come in and what can you do do you feel
to influence the course of events for
instance can you get some kind of
parliamentary vote on the process
perhaps further down the line and not
just on this great repeal bill do you
think you can make common cause with
people in other parties to do that well
it there's no doubt that there's a lot
of us in
Parliament who do you feel that it would
be extraordinary given that the brexit
vote was about the sovereignty of
Parliament and of this country in terms
of making our laws that phrase of taking
back control whatever it means for
Parliament not to have a big say in the
brexit negotiations as they unfold on
the guiding principles to be asking
questions yeah I hope tomorrow for
example that you know a member of the
cabinet whether it's David Davis or
somebody else will come to Parliament
and make a statement that's what
normally happens when Parliament hasn't
been sitting when there been some big
developments as there were over the
party conference the announcements
coming to Parliament to tell Parliament
this is the stage that we have got to
and yes I think there will be common
cause between those of us who want there
to be the right brexit the right
mechanism for leaving the EU but the
other thing is that the Conservative
Party manifesto on which we were elected
only seventeen months ago has a very
clear statement in it about we say yes
to the single market and it talks about
we will safeguard British interests in
the single market and that's something
that the government cannot ignore the
Conservative Party my conservative
colleagues cannot ignore we stood on a
manifesto saying that as well as saying
we'd have a referendum we would respect
the result which we will but actually we
have to make sure that we do not throw
away access the single market just
because that means talking about free
movement so further down the line as a
deal comes in to shape you would like to
see Parliament retaking sovereignty
Parliament having a decision well that's
I think what everybody seems to be
saying campaigners on the lee side the
Prime Minister was talking about
sovereignty of Parliament upon making
their own the laws and having a say in
this negotiation and you know and I
think boat and I think we as members of
parliament are very mindful even those
of us who are very Pro remain are very
mindful of the vote on the 23rd of June
what people wanted the majority
seventeen million have voted to leave
the EU but there is a 48 percent as a 16
million of whom I've had a lot of
contact from in the last few days saying
you know please make sure you make the
case for the best possible deal and have
you had contacts from the former Labour
leader Ed Miliband we hear he's
yeah boarding the papers there he's
given the Conservatives know what I
haven't well I look I will sir I will
speak to to to everyone and because I
think this is such a momentous issue for
the United Kingdom I think we can all
agree on that whatever side of the
debate that we on this is a huge thing
for the United Kingdom it is going to
affect our future for decades to come
which is why we've got to get it right
and I think people expect their members
of parliament to be holding the
government to account to be asking those
questions and isn't it interesting that
actually you've got people like pat
you've got people whether it's Ed
Miliband or others it's not the labor
front bench who are asking those
questions so it's incumbent on others of
us to do that you must be getting a lot
of flack from some members of your own
party actually I'll say no and then I'll
probably look at my Twitter timeline and
look at my inbox after after that but I
think people understand that it's
incumbent on those of us but it is
who've been in government who understand
how government works to ask those
constructive questions about do we have
the right deal what are the negotiating
principles where are we hoping to end up
now what damage could we do to our
economy what damage can we avoid doing
to our economy and that's what we will
be asking do you think I mean there is a
school of thought that says with treasom
a that this was positioning at the
Conservative Party conference she after
all was I remain err maybe technically a
remainder but she had to then reassure
the party that she was going to carry
out brexit and having reassured them
she now has room for manoeuvre there are
going to be compromises inevitably in
these very very difficult negotiations
do you think that its political tactics
well I'm sure there's an element of that
I mean I think that in any party
conference speech you give you a think
about the audience that's in front of
you the reassurance is that people
wanted to hear but I don't think anyone
can doubt from what Theresa May has said
from July onwards that she is determined
to deliver brexit we surprised she took
this such a strong tank though not
particularly because I think at the
start of a negotiation you want to set
out your you know your your your stall
but I think other people clearly have
been look at the markets look at what's
happened to the value of the pound in
the last few days I think there are
people who have suddenly woken up the
fact that we are going to have a wholly
different relationship with the EU in a
matter of of years
and that's something that people are
going to have to factor into future
business issues but that's also the
other thing is the uncertainty that is
out there I was out knocking on doors
yesterday in my constituency no people
saying well we don't really know what
happens next I was talking some farmers
on Friday again all very uncertain for
them talking to a food manufacturing
business again very uncertain but then
their prices are beginning to go up the
price they're paying for for products so
it is important that actually that
that's what I was keen that the
government did signal they were going to
make progress of this last question I
mean do you think you've got an ally in
the cabinet for that viewpoint in in the
Chancellor in Philip Hammond well I
haven't spoken to it to Philip but I
know from my time as a Treasury Minister
the Treasury will have a very clear view
on what they want to see in terms of
negotiations in terms of tactics that
doesn't damage the British economy
because at the end of the day that will
benefit apps that you know on in this
country the people the prime minister
says rightly she wants to have support
those who are just about managing are
going to be most damaged if our economy
you know is is damaged by brexit because
that then affects their jobs and
livelihoods Nicky Morgan good to see you
thank you very much indeed